so uh david litt is a former barack
obama speechwriter
i've interviewed him on the program
really interesting guy to talk to you
can check out
the youtube archives or the website
archives to find my interview with david
litt
david litt was invited to newsmax
yesterday
presumably to talk about elon musk's
hosting of saturday night live on
saturday evening
and it went very similarly to the fox
news clip we looked at earlier of randy
weingarten
calling out fox news while on fox news
david lit went on newsmax and he called
them out
uh because of their deceptive and um
outrageous coverage of the 2020
election and i have to tell you this was
done
so expertly and it starts so subtly it's
introduced so
smoothly that it actually takes a second
for the newsmax host to even realize
what's going on
david lit says yeah you know saturday
night live they wrote stuff that wasn't
true
and they set it to their audience in
comedy format of course
and that's what newsmax did with the
2020 election coverage over the last
several months
it just wasn't comedy and this is how it
went
this one david lit good morning welcome
into wake up america nice to see you
thanks for having me um i did not watch
saturday night live i watched the clips
the show's on too late quite frankly i
don't think it's that funny anymore
um what'd you think of elon musk's
performance this is the first time since
2015 we've had a non-athlete
non-entertainer on the show
the last person to do that and do well
with great ratings
our former president donald trump well
rob it's a great question i mean what
happened
on snl this weekend was that people made
stuff up
and then said it on television like it's
true and that actually happens pretty
frequently in american tv for example in
2020
dominion voting system sued newsmax over
its false claims
about election fraud newsmax was lying
to its own viewers and newsmax had to
settle
that lawsuit so i'm actually i just need
to check in are you still telling that
lie are you telling new lies
wait are we talking about i'm sorry
david are we talking about do you want
to talk about something completely
non-related and try to catch me on a
monday morning totally off topic or do
you want to talk about elon musk
i just love the reference from the host
to monday morning david lit you know
on a tuesday afternoon this would be
acceptable
how dare you try this on me on a monday
morning and this is actually something
that's done really frequently
when a host is pushed up against a wall
or made uncomfortable they often will go
back to
this isn't what we booked you to talk
about i've sometimes done this as a
guest sometimes guests when the guest is
sandbagged
the guest will say you didn't book me to
talk about this
and it's a rhetorical crutch you just
have to be prepared for how to handle it
unless you've agreed not to talk about
something
you just have to be prepared as the host
or as the guest
i've had situations we've had maybe two
or three situations where a guest
or their publicist will say listen
please don't
ask about x because there's ongoing
litigation
just can't comment on it and it's going
to bring the interview to a halt and of
course
i have the option as the host of saying
well i will ask about it but the guest
can say i'm not able to to talk about
that right now
or it might not even really be a central
topic and i would say oh yeah that's not
the topic of the interview anyway
i've been on shows where they give me a
list of eight topics and say we might
talk about these things
and i have said before i don't know
anything about topic number five
so i'd rather not talk about it if you
ask me i'll just say i don't know about
that so i'm not the right person to ask
and we sort of come to an agreement
other than that it's basically just a
rhetorical game
and sometimes when a guest will turn
around and start asking the host
questions the host will do the i'm
asking the
questions here you're here as my guest
and then it's just sort of like a battle
of rhetoric there's no like set
rules about this it's really up for
interpretation
and here the host really comes off like
a loser quite frankly let's continue
well i can see why you don't want to
talk about dominion voting systems
because
if you do newsmax could get sued and
lose billions of dollars because these
are live
david david david that's listen
david that's fine david i know this is a
very funny moment for you i'm sure you
didn't sleep last night as you prepared
to sort of try and get the morning
anchor on newsmax
i'd be happy to talk with you about
whatever you want to talk about
obviously it's not the topic that we
have set up for right now
so if you'd like to talk about saturday
night live i will do that with you but
obviously i'm not going to talk about
anything else
right now so you decide right now in
this moment on live television go ahead
did dominion voting systems have any
impact on the 2020 election
oh that's unfortunate because i was
really excited about this interview i
didn't watch snl on saturday night but i
thought elon musk did an okay job and he
also said that he's got asperger's so i
thought that was a
fascinating component of the monologue
so david we look forward to having him
back on very soon again that was a
stellar interview david litt thanks so
much for joining us
we'll be right back so yeah just cutting
off the interview
and it reminds me by the way the the
mention of asperger's or
as the host says ass burgers there's a
reason we no longer
say aspergers and instead say you know
high functioning autism or
low low severity autism spectrum
disorder
dr hans asperger did work linked to
nazism
nazi child psychiatry there's a debate
because asperger himself i guess was a
resistor
a nazi a resistor to the nazis but many
children that were identified by him as
having
so-called aspergers were subsequently
killed by nazis
so i was actually surprised that elon
musk even used that term
to describe his own condition maybe
that's a topic for another day
i like what david lit did here it did
get cut off pretty quickly
but there's really no other way to
pierce the news max filter bubble uh
because otherwise you know you can talk
about newsmax on other channels
but going on newsmax and doing it there
i think it's fantastic i loved it for
for me
it's perfect for a monday morning monday
morning is like the perfect day
to do what david did and quite frankly
it was kind of funnier than a lot of
recent saturday night live skits i have
not been super impressed
with snl recently um nice job by david
litt
and hopefully we'll have more of these
upcoming